Tomasa talking motto was the controlling force of the Spanish inquisition.
He presided over the systematic purging of the so called heretic Jews that has
gone down in history as one of the worst religious persecutions of all time.
But was he the monster that history is painted well in this week's biographics,
we uncover the real story of Tomas to talk to Marta.
Yeah,
it's a monster talking motto was born in 1420 in or around the village of OLED
and the Kingdom of old Castiel in modern day Spain.
The talk martyrs were of Jewish heritage.
However,
Tomasa's forbears had converted to Catholicism to become what we're known as
converses or converted ones.
His was a distinguished family with an uncle John,
who had joined the Dominican order into us making advancements in the royal
palace in Rome in 1431 John to talk motto was made master if the palace and then
in 1439 a cardinal with an uncle in such a high position in the Catholic Church.
The Path was set for young to master,
make his own mark within the church from a young age,
he sees the opportunity.
He was a diligent students who develops a reputation as a pious and humble young
man.
Prior to the age of 10 he was admitted to the San Pablo Dominican monastery.
For the next two decades.
His life revolved around ecclesiastical study,
prayer,
confession,
and church custom.
At around the age of 35 he became prior of the Dominican convent at Segovia.
For the next 20 years talking,
Marta presided over his small parish living the life of a humble,
quiet man of God.
He developed a reputation as an energetic and fearless preacher of the word and
a strict disciplinarian,
the facts that he was strictest on himself because the people in his community
to look at his as a fine example of piety and to holiness,
he refused to eat meat.
He slaps on a bad boards in which not wear anything other than his old habits.
He was also a voracious reader and had a fascination with architecture,
especially that of the church
up until the 15th century.
The rulers of Casteel and Aragon governed a series of separate districts
kingdoms within the Iberian peninsula.
It was the marriage of Isabella of Castiel to Ferdinand of Aragon in 1469 which
began the gradual process of unification that would lead to the creation of
modern day Spain.
It was around 1470 you and talking Marta became acquainted with Princess
Isabella who was then in our young twenties the princess was spending quite a
lot of time in Segovia and s with doc and Marta having established quite a
reputation as a holy man.
Of Note,
he was retained as how confessor at first he declined to accepts the offer that
was won over by the princesses insistence.
On December the 13th 1474 Isabella was crowned queen of Castiel and Leon.
Her relationship with talking motto had and she came to rely on him for advice.
Isabella and talking about it,
they were both obsessed with rooting out religious heresy and the purity of the
church.
Both the queen and husband's King Fudge and atoms had a high opinion of the
humble priest and he was quickly promoted within the order.
If he had been ambitious,
he may have ascended to a cause,
an oil ship like his uncle,
even to the office of Pope.
But talking about,
uh,
he had no such lofty intentions.
He was content's to live the life of a simple monk.
In May of 1475,
the Portuguese invaded Spain and it attempts to seize the crown away from
Isabella and Ferdinand's.
A bloody war was waged familia year culminating in the Spanish victory at the
battle of Toro on March the first 1476 in the wake of this great victory is
about a road around the countryside holding court in every town that she came
across as she would hear complaints about murderers,
thieves,
and other wrongdoers using her authority as Monique to fast track judicial
process.
She would order the guilty to either be short or beheaded immediately.
This she did with a cold and clinical and precision,
not this time token Mata was busy with organizing the construction of a new
Dominican monastery.
At a villa.
Jews had been living in Spain for some 1,500 years with about 80,000 of them.
At the time Isabella was queen.
This was compared to some 6 million Christians.
Unlike France and England's,
the Spanish had not expelled the Jews,
but they had forced many of them to convert to Christianity.
These were the ones who were known as convert Zos.
Many within the realm,
however,
did not put any stock in the Christian sincerity of the conveyor Zos.
They were believed to be false converts who practice their own Jewish religion
while professing Christianity.
This was seen by many in positions of power of direct threat to the security of
the realm in general and to the church in particular in the eyes of the queen.
This faith amounted to Paris.
He and it was something that she simply would not tolerate.
In fact,
she would not put up with any form of religious hypocrisy.
It was during a visit to Seville and 1477 that she first became interested in
adopting an inquisition or investigation into the religious state of the
kingdom.
The following year,
a papal bull was issued by pope six does the fourth granting permission to
establish an inquisition within Castiel.
The petitions of the pipe requesting the inquisition had been written by talking
Mada and Cardinal Mendoza,
but Isabella,
she moved cautiously.
She was of the opinion that poor training was the main reason that Jewish
converts when not fully adhering to the faith.
And so she put the emphasis on religious education.
The queen appointed two of them.
Most trusted church advises Cardinal Mendoza and the future archbishop of
Granada and Nando de Talavera to the task of reeducating the way it would
converse.
So a program was put in place in Seville by which local priests would retrain
the misguided converses.
But after two years with very little headway being made,
Isabella had concede that stronger measures when needed,
she remains reluctance to enact the inquisition.
But pressure came upon her from her advisors,
including talking Marta to do so.
Even her husband,
King Ferdinand was in favor of the pragmatist.
He foresaw the confiscation of conversa property has a much needed revenue
gathering source for the state.
Finally,
and against her better judgment.
Isabella are issued a royal decree on September the 27 1480 establishing the
tribunal of the Holy Office of the inquisition.
The Papal Bull authorizing the acquisition had given us a better and Fudge
Nan's,
the freedom to select the members who made up the inquisition tribunals.
They chose Tamasic talking and along with college nor Mendoza and two other
Dominicans,
Frey,
Miguel Morello and Frey Juan to some Martine Mendoza.
It took the position of chief judge while talking.
Mata took the position of consulting x spat the other two members where the
active inquisitor's who sought out and it's brought heretics before the
tribunal.
The first area of focus for the inquisition was the almost entirely Jewish city
of Seville.
The arrival living twisters dressed in distinctive white robes and black hoods
caused panic among the conversa community.
With around 4,000 people fleeing Savelle,
still the inquisitors set about their work with ruthless efficiency.
The first public execution took place on February the sixth 1481 on that day,
six people were burned to death setting the stage for the horror that was to
unfold over the coming months and years from Seville.
The inquisition spread throughout the kingdom with tribunals set up in Cordoba,
Yay.
And to the religious Capitol of Toledo.
A passing was soon established,
would begin with the people of a town being prepared by having the fear of God
preached to them from the pulpit.
Then the inquisitors would arrive in the town and the edict of grace would be
red.
This was a cool to come forth and confess your lack of faith.
Those who did so and renounced their Judaism.
Good Hope for mercy.
Those who didn't would face the full wrath of the inquisitor's.
Those who were taken into detention would have all of their property taken away
from them.
This would obviously leave their family and a hopeless situation.
The primary goal of the interrogators was to obtain a confession.
It didn't matter if it came voluntary or if torture had to be used to extract
it.
Methods of torture progressed from foot roasting in which the suspect's fees,
well loved and fashion than held over a burning fire to the Judas cradle.
A device composed of a tall,
thin stool with a triangular shaped seat in which the victim was sodium pails.
And then there was the rack,
in which case the victim was tied to a wooden frame and their body was stretched
as the ball's moved in opposite directions.
Such torture would convince even the most innocent of people to confess.
Still subject coerced confession was not legally binding.
It had to be afterwards confirmed by the suspect for it to hold any weight.
The trial that was held would be the defendants only opportunity to defend
himself if he was able to,
he would call upon witnesses to prove his innocence or to cast doubt upon the
voracity of the accuser.
If found guilty,
the person could be reconciled or pennants if they demonstrated can triteness,
they would lose all their property and have to undergo such punishments is
whipping or a term of imprisonment.
Those who refuse to denounce Judaism would be condemned to the flames.
The inquisition created an atmosphere of fear throughout the kingdom.
One of its most chilling aspects was that it thrived on a diet of anonymous
accusation.
Then when the suspect who was forced to confess,
he was required to produce names of others who had been co-conspirators with
him.
By 1483 the inquisition had become a monster that was completely out of control.
Isabella's initial goal was simply to weed out the false converts among the
conversion of Jews,
but the climate of accusation and torture had led to something far,
far more sinister with no centralized control.
The various tribunals around the kings and were operating according to their own
dictates.
News was constantly being received by the pope in Rome of accesses that when's B
owns the powers that he had given it as papal bull.
This call was tension between the Pope and queen is about in order to settle the
situation,
Isabella tend to hire advisors at Thomas did Torquemada.
It was decided that all the powers of the inquisition would be decentralized
with token WMATA himself at the hat.
He had the skills and experience it was believed to please both of a Monique and
the pope at the same time.
The pope of greed stands in October of 1483 he names talking Marta.
The inquisitor general of Castiel and the owner.
In contrast,
the history's painting him as an ego,
persecutor of Jews.
He was chomping at the bits to torture them.
The truth is that talk Amada would rather not have taken up the position.
He would have preferred to continue to live the simple life of a monk.
Yes,
having accepted the position,
he did take it on with full force knots with the goal of persecuting the Jews
there,
but ensuring that all Catholics were true as loyal Catholics.
He's all the inquisition,
not as an instrument of crew Tara,
but as a vehicle for necessary reform talk a Marta began his oversight of the
inquisition by doing a way with the worst excesses of his predecessors,
putting in place a system of judicial process.
He then improve the conditions for people who were imprisoned under the
inquisition.
Talk about,
uh,
next set about refining veep.
Stages of the inquisition process.
The edict of grace would be read up to three times into period of 40 days given
for repentant ones to come forward.
A person could only be convicted on the testimony of two witnesses.
And now the complaints had to be in writing and they had to be signed.
Once a person was denounced by two witnesses,
he would be investigated usually without his knowledge.
If evidence of false religious worship was clear and specific,
the person would be put before the court talk.
Amada required that a person's trial must be held within three days of his.
The charges against him would be state.
It didn't.
He would be urged to confess to his gills if he refused up to two more hearings
would be held only after the third hearing with the interrogation begin talk on
Mars and produced a handbook to help his inquisitors do identify heretical
converses giveaway signs of their heresy where such things as cooking all their
meals for the weekend on a Friday night if they got their supplies from Jewish
rather than Kristy and suppliers,
and if they were known not to eat pork just by the fact that his name has been
forever linked with the worst excesses of the inquisitions torture processes.
The reality is that talk Amada was responsible for mitigating the worst excesses
of the process.
He stipulated that it was not to be used as a means of punishment,
but strictly for obtaining information related to the charge at hands.
Furthermore,
torture could only be administered with the recent approval of the bishop of the
diocese and the visa of the Supreme Court.
In addition,
the doctor had to be present throughout the torture process.
Talk about that.
Did away with some of the more barbarous methods of torture and replaced them
with what was known as the water care.
The interrogated person would be stripped naked and tied with cords.
Upon a wooden ladder.
The nostrils stopped and his drawers were held apart by tongues.
Then a piece of linen was placed over his mouth.
Water was then slowly pour it onto the cloth to travel down the throat.
The sensation that resulted was that one was suffocating.
However it Randy resulted in long term.
Harmon's usually resulted in a confession being obtained talk,
Amada organized a Sonata,
the inquisitor's Seville during which she impressed upon the tribunal members
his new rules.
He then convenes tribunals in old Jewish strongholds including Seville,
Cordoba,
Gian,
and [inaudible]
with the inquisition now and out and could still talk to Marta.
Now set about implementing is in Aragon.
This was a challenging assignment.
The gene is Helen.
Plenty of positions of power and these men were naturally resistance to the
inquisition review.
Again,
the governor of Arizona and along with most of the judges and lawyers in the
stage where all converges those,
they all banded together and opposition to the work of talking motto.
Still the chief inquisitive forged ahead.
They appointed two of his best men as inquisitors for Aragon.
Leaving is meant to it.
He then returned to focus on carrying out the inquisition and Castiel.
Meanwhile,
Jewish leaders in both states,
we're organizing an opposition to the inquisition.
A great campaign for democracy was launched,
two monks web centre Cordoba to besiege the Queens,
but an end to the inquisition.
The men often large sums of money to the crown.
However,
Isabella rejected all of their efforts.
Now desperate,
the Jewish leaders began to speak of assassinating the inquisitor's.
A group of prominent Jews met together and agreed to hire a gang of cutthroats
to carry out the assassinations.
They began by disposing of high ranking priests within the inquisition.
Father PTO abuse was kneeling in prayer before the blessed sacrament when a
gangster crept in and stabbed him in the back,
the and queen with outrage that this attack and twins all out to hunt down the
people who are responsible,
the gang who had been employed to carry out the Giddings,
they were rounded up and execute it.
Meanwhile,
the death of the priest who had immediately been raised to st Jude lead to a
backlash against the conversion.
Any oppositions of the inquisition in Aragon now came to an end allowing talking
about a free reign to bring the Jews there too is true faith in the course of
his inquiries into the Jewish activity is talking about are uncovered a plot by
converse,
a leaders in Toledo to seize control of the city during the 1485 Corpus Christi
Prosecution and murder or the leading Christians.
As a result,
a large number of Jewish leaders are put to death
off to 12 years.
The inquisition had still not managed to stomp out of the Jewish heresy problem.
Talking motto was of the belief that the reason that the conversa is we're not
fully engaged with Catholicism was because they still associated with the Jewish
community.
I only by putting an end to this association with the problem be solved.
Consequently,
he began putting pressure on the king and Queen's you issue an edict expanding
all Jews from Spain.
Then in 1495 Jews and six conveys A's were accused of crucifying and measuring a
Christian child in the village of the Goddamn the accusation.
It was probably false,
but it led to an unprecedented antisemetic backlash.
Finally,
in March of 1492 Isabella and Ferdinand and sign their names to a documents
which ordered that all Jews who had not converted to Christianity,
where to leave the kingdom.
By August the second 1492 around 160,000 people manage to get out before the
deadline.
Most of them sold their possessions for a pittance and were forced to travel as
far as Africa,
the Balkans,
and Rome before finally finding a place to settle.
Many of them are unable to find a place where they would be accepted straggled
back to Spain to be baptized as Catholics.
Others reportedly paid exorbitant prices for passage on ships,
Sony to be killed at sea and thrown overboard.
The number of Jews who remained in Spain is convert.
Those was far greater than those who had left and despite the worst efforts if
the inquisition,
they remains Jewish believers at hot.
However,
these conversions now had no Jewish cultural support to back them up.
They were completely on their own synagogues throughout the lands where I've
taken over and claimed for the Catholic Church by now talking about it,
it was at the height of his power.
He had unfettered control if the inquisition and was a key player in the royal
household.
The combination of the inquisition,
nams,
the Jewish expulsion,
had insured the Catholicism would remain untainted
in 1494 talk Martin now age 74 again to suffer the effects of old age,
his body lacks to the energy he wants ads into struggle to compete as duties as
grand inquisitor.
Pope Gregory the fourth appointed for assistant inquisitors to lighten the load.
In that same year,
Isabella and Ferdinand gift attended the Jewish cemetery at a villa for him to
use as his own monastery.
It was here that he died peacefully on September the 16th 1498 the acquisition
was to survive talking motto by 300 Years Spreading throughout the Spanish el
territory,
including Naples,
the Spanish Netherlands,
and the territory held by Spain and the Americas.
The inquisition remains one of the worst examples of man's inhumanity towards
man and the man who led it.
Tomas Talking Mazda is one of history's most hated figures,
so I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos twice a week.
Also,
hit that notification bell if you actually want to hear about those videos,
subscribe doesn't do what it used to on Youtube and as always,
thank you for watching.